kardashian 41 will hold the honorary
title of chieftain consultant
she will star in a new advertising
campaign for the alternative meet firm
and the reality television star will
also share details about her preferred
beyond meet items in a company released
newsletter that will also include
personalized recipes yeah i'm sure kim
kardashian first of all i'm sure she's
cooking her own food come on
come on and secondly i'm sure she's at
home writing those recipes up
in her spare time
okay
come on people come on
this is what she said though at the time
and she later got heat by the way
because the video came out it looked
like she wasn't eating the burger and
people were like you didn't really eat
it so then she filmed another video
where she was eating the burger it was a
whole big thing i didn't care about that
part though i care about this part
that's what she says
i'm really inspired by beyond meat's
mission and love that they are not only
making plant-based eating delicious and
accessible but are doing so in a way
that benefits both people and the planet
so she's saying it's healthy that's what
i gather from that okay it's not
it's not i realize i'm not going to get
any beyond burger sponsorships here but
i'm cool with that
so i want to take you just take a look
at the beyond burger ingredients i don't
know if you have that link tyler you can
pull it up and i have it here
ingredients for a beyond burger
water pea protein expeller pressed
canola oil refined coconut oil rice
protein natural flavors when you see
natural flavors on something that means
they didn't want to tell you what was in
it natural flavors by the way guys is
like fragrance
when you look at a bottle and it says
organic and then it says fragrance what
that means is that they take a bunch of
toxic chemicals together hundreds
sometimes thousands and they group them
together to make something smell pretty
and you don't know what's in it don't
buy stuff that says fragrance you want
some fragrance get some essential oils
something natural in there fragrance and
natural flavors are brothers so what's
natural flavors i don't know
neither do you and oftentimes when you
call these companies because i've done
it and ask they won't tell you
dried yeast cocoa butter methyl
cellulose that's a binder and less than
one percent of potato starch salt
potassium chloride beet juice color
apple extract goes on and on and on
okay
this is not healthy
it would be really great i should have
juxtaposed this next to a grass-fed
grass-finished farm
you know raised on a beautiful farm
piece of meat you know what the
ingredients are in that meat
meat
okay
this stuff is not good for you
it's not good for you i'm going to go on
and then i'm going to get back to a
little bit
about a little bit more on this
so she calls it healthy she calls it
healthy
interestingly enough the announcement
provided it says in the post article an
initial bump to beyond meets shares but
the stock turned eight percent lower
by late morning oh maybe people didn't
buy what she was selling i can't imagine
why
okay
so that's beyond me kim kardashian comes
out she does that whole thing i'm not on
the air to talk about it i do go on a
bit of a rant on twitter telling people
this is not real food now let me explain
something to you this is not a hit on
people who eat plant-based i was
plant-based for years
when i was younger
i had acid reflux bad really really bad
um due to stress due to horrible eating
habits i used to eat horribly in college
i developed severe case of reflux where
they stuck me on
prilosec they stuck me on nexium they
stuck me on all that stuff those proton
pump inhibitors they're all
anyway it didn't work out so well for me
i ultimately went to a nutritionist a
guy called joel furman out in new jersey
one of the first guys to be talking
about food we talked about food i went
on a plant-based diet for years
you can do plant-based if you have a
problem with meat
okay that's up to you
some people have a problem with it
because they you know are are very
active in animal causes animal rights
okay that's your thing i get it i
understand there's a way to do
plant-based that's healthy this isn't it
when i was plant-based i didn't eat fake
meat
okay a lot of fruits i ate a lot of
vegetables i ate dehydrated nuts and
seeds i ate a lot of good stuff a lot of
healthy stuff this wasn't it okay this
is garbage this is garbage food
so somebody who knows about health and
knows about food is not going to be
recommending this to you somebody you
walk into a nutritionist office and they
tell you to go get some beyond meat
save your money walk right on out
so this story hits
i see all this i'm like what's going on
then this past weekend i see kourtney
kardashian because you know something
happens in the kardashian family you
ever notice this one sister and then
suddenly it's like whoa all the sisters
kourtney kardashian and travis barker
feed each other vegan chicken and
seductive new campaign
just from people by the way so let's see
what's going on here
the pair who had their third wedding in
italy almost a month ago
are celebrating newlywed bliss by
revealing a saucy campaign with vegan
chicken company daring
in true crevice style the newly released
photos feature a lot of intimate moments
kardashian is mindful to keep a balanced
primarily plant-based diet this is her
comment on it
oh yeah we're going to get back to that
photo
she says i've been on a health and
wellness journey for the past 13 years
which has made me super conscious of
what i put into my body and my kids
bodies i'm not fully vegan but travis
has helped me to keep to a mostly
plant-based diet which is so much easier
with daring
okay so let's look i went i was like
let's see what what's in it i'm an
ingredient list junkie
i go over to the daring site
and i look
i do some digging and i see that daring
is made from a few they claim simple
natural ingredients and packed with
plant protein
water soy protein concentrate that's not
good for you sorry
sunflower oil terrible that's a seed oil
that's inflammatory
salt not even sea salt y'all not even
some celtic sea salt and there are some
pink himalayan
natural flavor there it is again what's
that no one knows spices okay
again
you can do plant-based you can do
plant-based healthy this is not how you
do it you want to go make up you know
vegetables some beans that you soak the
night before
some nuts and seeds you want to do some
fruits you want to do some cassava pasta
do a little pesto homemade with some
spinach you do that
this is not healthy now i'm in a
different place right now i happen to be
consuming meat i happen to be in a
mental space personally where i'm seeing
a lot of added benefits to adding some
of these meats that come from farms that
really practice you know good practices
i'm seeing that so i'm not on a
plant-based head right now but i
understand everybody goes through
different phases in life and everybody's
body is different and your body at 20 is
not your body at 40 is not your body at
35.
so i respect people's individual
decision-making processes what i have a
problem with is celebrities
who sell things to people that aren't
good for them under the guise of them
being some type of health expert
that's what i have a problem with you
will not see me promoting something on
this show that i don't believe in it's
not going to happen i claim to care
about health
wait and see what gets promoted on this
show i'll eat my words if it's not 100
something that i use at home something
that i would endorse something that i
think is good for you me for my kid
100 promise from me
she you think she's eating this meat
tyler
do you think honestly do you think him
courtney sit around the table at night
and they eat beyond burgers and daring
uh no i don't think their personal chefs
cook them beyond burger or daring
chicken on a on a nightly basis yeah
that i don't think they're eating this i
don't know for sure but i just don't
think so you know they know how to make
a lot of money though they sure know how
to make a lot of money and what's also
interesting to me this one really had me
if you go to the daring site this is
amazing
they do a comparison on their site and
they're like
daring is way better
than these frozen chicken strips
okay
well did you do a comparison between
daring and pasture-raised chicken from a
farm
did you do that
yeah daring loses
so this is a problem for me because i
feel like these
first of all there's a new movement
that's happening the anti-meat movement
it's bad for the climate
it's bad for the animals
it's good for you but you know
why is this happening and why are all
these high-level influencers you got
bill gates you know who invests in a lot
of this stuff he's out there talking
about buying up a ton of land by the way
we're going to get to that we're going
to get to all of that
but why why would these people
be advocating for something that's not
good for you well there's a lot of money
in that game
and then when you have a population and
i'm not talking about the kardashians
here they're not thinking that deep on
this issue but somebody like bill gates
i wonder just a question not a
declarative statement
would somebody like that benefit in any
way from a population that wasn't super
healthy i don't know
would somebody like that and his other
investments he's big pharma guy
promoting all these big pharma drugs all
the time i wonder does big pharma
benefit
when a population is not healthy
is more sick is more prone to chronic
disease is more medication dependent and
has to roll into big pharma every month
for a prescription
and has to rely on big pharma for a
whole bunch of stuff because their body
is toxic waste toxic waste dump
i don't know
maybe so the kardashians have an
incredible amount of influence and power
people love them
i have to admit i was never a kardashian
fan i love reality tv in fact i just ate
up those shows that nick lachey and
vanessa lachey put out there
the couples oh we're gonna oh we're
gonna cover some of those and we're
gonna have some guests from those shows
i'm so excited
i love reality tv i was a road rules
versus real world kind of girl
i watched fear factor back when joe
rogan was the guy doing that i was
always like that's my job this guy's
always got my job now that i think about
it
now that i think about it joe rogan's
always got my job fear factor and now
the number one podcast okay joe i see
how it is
but seriously i used to watch that show
and be like oh that's my job i love that
i'm a daredevil
so i love reality tv love it never could
get into the kardashians just always
seemed like there was a veneer of just
fake going on there
and i don't know i don't know if the
kardashians are the best advocates for
health in many ways just my opinion
if you're an influencer if you're
someone out there who has people's ears
and eyes know that
it's not just a money game you have you
have
the eyes and ears of young kids you have
the eyes and ears of people who trust
you it can't just be about money
you can make money go with a company
that's actually producing real food do
do think about they don't need money
they don't need the money
think about what you're doing as an
influencer as somebody i mean these
people have millions and billions and
millions of followers what they do
affects other people like it or not i
may not like it you may not like it it
affects other people be responsible be
responsible you can endorse whatever you
want you can endorse whatever you want
but you don't get to call it healthy
or you can call it healthy actually and
i'm going to come in and tell everybody
why it's not
that is sad to me
you want to do something healthy for
your body eat some fruits and vegetables
eat some real food that's not out of a
box
figure out which farms raise their
animals properly no hormones known
antibiotics you know pasture raised
grass-fed grass finish do that research
and figure that out and by the way
people say to me when i talk about this
well you're rich
you talk about this it's expensive so
let me tell you i changed my eating
habits on a teacher's salary
i was making 42 000 a year living in
that eighteen hundred dollar a month
apartment and i was eating all whole
food i took my entire salary and i put
it into food
all of it i didn't go out drinking i
didn't go out to dinner i didn't buy
myself stuff i wasn't a clothes horse
like oh my closet is filled with
designer clothes didn't do any of that
because i knew that food was going to
make a difference in how i feel and
longevity
that's what i chose to invest in and you
can do it on a small salary you can be
smart about it you absolutely can
especially if you're not eating any meat
it was so easy
that i'm not going to pretend they know
about health we're not going to pretend
here we're not going to account for the
phonies
all right
and a lot of indoctrination goes on with
that stuff too keep that in mind a lot
of indoctrination now the new trend is
plant-based everything's got to be
plant-based or your anti-climate
i'm getting tired of the indoctrination
if you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]
you